well I am going to tell you about a post
today in which the failed former
president Donald Trump defecates on the
Constitution now hold the whoa whoa hold
it I'm not literally going to show you
scat videos so don't you don't have to
turn away you don't have to get the kids
out of the room yet although if
absolutely brutalizing the Constitution
and using it like toilet paper is
offensive to you then maybe you do want
to get the kids out of the room Donald
Trump in an absolutely Constitution
destroying rant
demanded for a new 2020 election or to
be reinstated as president of the United
States under the continued false claim
that he is the so-called rightful winner
of the 2020 election Trump exploding on
his platform truth social essential well
call it what you want
over the Twitter bombshell that flopped
into a nothing Burger
saying the following quote so with the
revelation of the massive and widespread
fraud and deception in working closely
with big tech companies the DNC and the
Democrat Party
do you throw the presidential election
results of 2020 out
and declare the rightful winner
or do you have a new election a massive
fraud of this type and magnitude allows
for the termination of all rules
regulations and articles even those
found in the Constitution
he's literally saying the Constitution
is not the supreme law and framework of
the land he's saying when we decide
there are extenuating circumstances you
terminate this is the word terminate
rules regulations and articles he goes
on to say our great quote capital F
founders
I don't know what's weirder that it's
Inc with a capital effort that it's in
quotes it's both are weird our great
Founders did not want
and would not condone
capital F false and capital F fraudulent
capital e
elections
the Constitution means nothing to them
if it's not convenient this is brutal
brutal authoritarianism it's all
meaningless
unless it is convenient to them and
there Donald Trump says I don't know it
just sort of seems like we've got to
eliminate or circumvent better said the
Constitution so that he can somehow end
up back in office now think for a second
of the insanity of the situation
former president
who lost and is again a candidate is
saying maybe just put me back in office
maybe let's skip me doing two years of a
Republican primary or a year however
like a year and a half and then in
general election and then having people
vote we can skip all of it terminate as
he says what is he thinks he's Arnold
Schwarzenegger terminate the
Constitution
maybe just put me back in power
and the most insane part of this is
Republicans aren't even going that wild
it should be
instantly disqualifying
for a candidate for the presidency to
say sometimes we terminate the
Constitution we just terminate it now if
you want to have a conversation about we
need a constitutional amendment oh okay
well we have a process for that if you
want to have a conversation about
should a document like the Constitution
be revised over time in some more
General sense that's a completely
legitimate conversation to have it's not
about we can never I'm not asking to
have it both ways because many of us on
the Progressive left say
a document that is this old
no matter how great the intentions were
of those who wrote it and believe what
you believe about that right no matter
how great the intentions were no matter
how much how forward looking they
planned to be
at a certain point we have to be able to
say
it needs modern context and you know you
can argue about whether
a few hundred years is enough time but
do we think that the constitution would
be relevant in 500 years in a thousand
years in 1500 years without significant
revision or contextualization sure let's
have that conversation but that's not
what Donald Trump is saying Donald Trump
is not saying there are aspects of the
Constitution which in general need to be
revised modified amended whatever the
case may be Trump is just saying keep
the Constitution the way it is just
ignore it when it comes to me figuring
out a way to get back into power
I'm going to give you one example of a
uh Republican
who
seems like she's not going for this
Insanity unfortunately for a lot of them
uh they are going for it and we're going
to get to that uh probably on tomorrow's
program but here is Alice Stewart she is
a Republican strategist former Ted Cruz
communications director she doesn't like
this but there are many Republicans who
are just kind of like that yeah I mean I
don't agree
but uh Trump may be the best choice we
have this device and I hate to inform
the former president the Constitution
does not like a spouse you can't just
get rid of it when it no longer suits
your purposes the Constitution is here
to protect the rights of all Americans
it is not there to change the past
election of a self-serving American and
he is wrong on this this is absolutely
ludicrous and I guarantee you Jim the
more you ask conservatives and
Republicans about this statement they
will say this is not right and they're
going to accept well we'll see about
that right themselves from these kinds
of statements yeah Alice the
Constitution is not like the buffet at
Mar-A-Lago you can't skip past the items
that you don't like
yeah listen
um I I guess you know there's things
have become the standard has become so
low
I guess I respect Alice Stewart for
saying this but at the same time all
she's saying is we have to mean it when
we say we respect the Constitution you
can't just ignore it when you just want
to use the you want to circumvent it in
order to get back in power
but it is absolutely not true that
Republicans are United against this it
should be political suicide to say what
Donald Trump said terminate the
Constitution so that you can get him
back in power because of Hunter Biden
pictures I mean at the end of the day
that's what we're talking about here but
we're seeing mild criticism from some
wings of the Republican party and uh
this type of thing I mean you know in
2022
a lot of Republicans ran on the election
was stolen and they didn't do very well
so it's at least possible possible that
some of the mainstream Republican party
is going to be further alienated by this
Insanity any clear thinking individual
who actually cares about the rule of law
even if we believe that the constitution
needs to be amended updated changed
whatever
by going through a process not in a rush
because we've got to terminate it to get
somebody back in power we can do that we
can talk about that but this type of
stuff needs to be rejected
everything you do online can be tracked
by your ISP by Tech platforms the
government hackers everyone should be
using a VPN every time you connect to
the internet you turn it on once you
forget about it it's easy many vpns
secretly record your browsing and
download history but our sponsor private
internet access is the only VPN with the
bulletproof commitment to never doing
that because they're the only VPN that
has proven their no log policy multiple
times in court their systems are also
independently audited by Deloitte to
verify no logging private internet
access has a Next Generation server
infrastructure with IP addresses in 83
countries and all 50 US states it's one
of the only vpns fast enough for
streaming video and downloading large
files for instance private internet
access lets me access a bunch of great
international soccer I can't otherwise
get VPN ends can be very helpful with
the upcoming World Cup and private
internet access has a 30-day money-back
guarantee 24 7 customer support and my
audience gets 82 percent off that's just
two dollars and eleven cents a month
plus three months free go to Pia vpn.com
David the link is in the podcast notes